hey everyone welcome to Simply learns
YouTube channel today we will learn
about the we lookup function which can
written multiple return values or
multiple R values in one query that's it
if these are the type of videos you'd
like to watch then hit that like And
subscribe buttons and the bell icon to
get notified just for your quick info if
you want to upskill yourself master
business analytic skills and land in
your dream job or growing your career
then you must explore simply learn goad
of various business analytics programs
simply learn offers postgraduate program
from PR University in collaboration with
Amazon Google and Microsoft through this
program you will gain a knowledge and
work ready expertise in skills like
prescriptive and Predictive Analytics
regression classification and over a
dozen others that's not all you also get
the opportunity to work on multiple
projects and learn from industry experts
in Top Tire product companies and
academicians from top universities after
completing these courses thousands of
Learners have transitioned into a
business analytics role as a fresher or
moved on a higher paying job profile if
you are passionate about making your
career in this field then make sure to
check out the link in the pin comment
and the description box below now
without further delay let's get back to
the Practical mode now I have started my
Microsoft Excel so here you can see I
have dealer quantity ordered price sales
product line country Etc now if I wanted
to apply vuka function and find out the
sales what Luxury Motors made and
obviously vuka will return me the first
row but if you see there are multiple
Luxury Motors available in the list now
what I want to do is whenever I give the
dealer as Luxury Motors I should get all
the available rules and all the data
related to Luxury Motors so we need to
modify a couple of things in our bookup
to get this done now let's get that done
so first we will try to tag the multiple
reputations of each and every dealer
that is we want to do a count or runtime
count so how to do that it's simple
equals to the first cell where we have
the values which is B2 and the function
which is Count
F and now the first C again and now
carefully look at that I'm trying to to
freeze
it so we have Frozen the first cell so
starting from the first cell to the last
cell right so yeah I think it's not
frozen let's try to freeze it once again
function F4 should freeze it now from B1
sorry I I mean to say the first cell B2
to B3 B4 B5 and BN so the first cell
will be fixed and the rest one will go
on as the function will be scrolled down
comma again B2
now close it and enter now you will see
what happens when I scroll it
down right so somewhere we have Luxury
Motors here so Luxury Motors is
available 13 times in this particular
data set now the first part of it is
done now we will go to the lookup part
so here equals to we look up everything
is absolutely same right you just need
to make few minor modifications to your
existing we lookup function the first
one is the running count which we made
here which we will be using shortly now
the lookup value so the V lookup
function now the lookup value okay we
did not specify the lookup value Escape
so we have this particular one let's
paste the same here and change the color
a little bit this will be our lookup
value so here equals to we look up now
the look up value and remember we are
not giving the exact value we are trying
to change a little so let's keep this as
fixed let's make sure that the lookup
value is always pointing to this
particular cell itself so let's freeze
it and along with that we will give some
other important attachment remember we
have the running count for all the
dealers here luxury mode 1 2 3 similarly
when you are trying to pull multiple
values or multiple rows then you might
want to give the individual identity to
that right so this is the first
occurrence second occurrence for that we
will use the row function so r o w row
and we are giving the row reference to
this particular cell right and U we want
that particular cell to start from
number one right currently we are at row
number two so let's give it as minus two
or sorry sorry minus one so from this
particular you can see that right here
it is row two so if you give it here it
will start with row two so if we
subtract minus1 the numbers will come
from one and uh this is the first part
after that we will give the lookup array
or table array so this is the table
array that I will be referring to there
you go comma now we can just give the uh
column number right let's say I wanted
to find sales so I'll give the sales uh
column number is 1 2 3 4 5 so what if I
wanted to get all the details right so
so in that situation we might have to
take use of index match functions so out
of that we will take only the match
function so let's call match function
press tab to select and now the lookup
value for match so your lookup value for
match will be this particular cell let's
try to freeze it there you go comma Now
in this particular freezing option you
might have to freeze the first row I
mean uh uh the I mean not row you have
to freeze the First Column that is I
column right you have to freeze this and
whenever you are trying to extend your
function it should dynamically change so
for that let's freeze it again now you
can see uh the row number one is frozen
but the column if you switch from dealer
to quantity order it will change so you
will understand this when I completely
finish the function right now the lookup
array so this is the lookup array we
should be looking at so from B this G
and now let's freeze it there you go
fora let's take the modified uh address
as well now the match type will be uh
true I mean let's me use the RP yes
match type so we want exact match so
zero press tab to select and close the
match function now the last type of or
the last parameter of the lookup
function we want exact match so false
press tab to select enter there you go
now we will copy Luxury Motors here and
paste it in the lookup value copy Luxury
Motors paste it here
enter there you
go we forgot to freeze this particular
address
yes very good now now what if I scroll
this we have all the appearances right
and you can understand wherever you have
any that is where the data ends you can
also try to you know modify this
wherever let's say uh if I adjust my
lookup function here if
error right then give
me zero or nothing or space whatever you
want let's give
space enter right now what happens is if
you extend this after a certain
occurrence you will only see space
bars which means it has ended there so
that's how uh you use multiple uh or
that's how you extract multiple rows
from one single lookup function instead
of this instead of this complex
calculation you can also use a filters
and it will also simplify your job so
it's another lesson for another day and
with that we have come to the end of
this session on how to get multiple rows
using one single V lookup function if
you have any queries regarding any of
the topics covered in this session or if
you require the resources like PP or the
data set that we used in this session
please do let us know in the comment
section below and our te of experts
we'll be happy to help you as soon as
possible until next time thank you for
watching and stay St for more from
Simply learn staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here